she was
like a typical loving mother so I was uh
dating for you heart of gold
71 year old cancer patient Noreen
Craig's family called 999 around New
Year when her health took a turn for the
worst on arrival here her loved ones say
she lay on a trolley in a side room no
beds available
I
actually felt sorry for the
what they had to deal with it was
ambulances everywhere and
does he just Carnage Noreen never made
it to a main word she died hours later I
think my mom would still be alive if she
was if she if they if she was given the
help that we were a promise she would be
if he was changed a proper one animals
would be treated beer
and the help and the care my mom
received any chance greater Glasgow and
Clyde has apologized to the family
this hospital here in Glasgow is one of
the UK's largest and it's also one of
the most Under Pressure senior doctors
suggest 40 people are dying each and
every week in Scotland as a direct
result of what they call an inhumane
crisis thousands of people are waiting
more than 12 hours just to be seen in
emergency departments hello Saturday
yeah it's next Thursday at the moment GP
surgery is also bearing the brunt in a
service enduring a pressure cooker
emergency
we basically get somebody shouting in
bowling is it every day at least once a
day consultations in red are emergency
consultations we would normally have 16
to 18 of those per day but look at
what's happening now that has gone up to
80.
John's been a doctor for more than 35
years this he says is Uncharted
Territory
this is the highest level of activity in
general Practice in Glasgow ever
recorded the reality is that people will
die there is that no question about that
this is this is not a safe sustainable
situation
a situation managed directly by the
Hollywood government in Edinburgh who
hope increasing NHS 111 Staffing will
reduce issues here at the sharp end
GP Sharon works from home taking those
calls we find that patients turn and
phone one-on-one initially first and if
they are waiting you know during the
peak times over Christmas where we were
seeing about 85 to 100 increase in
volume for patients to wait two three
hours on the phone would be really
frustrating
and the feeders those frustrations force
people to head to hospitals creating a
vicious circle in a creaking health
system on its knees Connor Gillis Sky
News Glasgow